hello
and welcome to dw's international
reporters magazine world stories with me
laila harack
coming up on today's show we take a
walking tour of moscow
plus if you're looking for a fright we
can recommend a place that will scare
the living daylights
out of you so stick around but we kick
off the show in the tiny rich gulf
nation of qatar
where camel racing is a popular national
sport
until recently it was shrouded in
controversy because of its widespread
use of child jockeys
many of these young boys faced a
harrowing ordeal traffic to the gulf
states
to compete as child camel jockeys they
were underfed to keep their weight as
low as possible
they were forced to risk their health
and their lives finally the practice was
banned
and as a result the game went into sharp
decline
that is until one man found an ingenious
way of tackling the problem
by reinventing the race untv's mary
ferreira reports on how
camel racing made a comeback by betting
on technology
camel racing thrived in the state of
qatar and all gulf countries
for decades lured by substantial cash
prizes
sometimes as high as 350 000 us dollars
owners did anything they could to win
even if it meant using children as
jockeys
children like russell who was only seven
years old when he was snatched by two
men from a railway station
in old dhaka
and then they took me away taken all the
way to dubai
qatar's neighbor russell was sold to a
camel owner
for 350 us dollars
that very first night they woke me up at
3 am
i was new to this work i fell several
times
we suffered a lot but we had to learn
the trafficking of young children and
their use as child jockeys
violates the un convention on the rights
of the child
for years unicef had led a campaign to
bring an
end to this practice rima salah
is a deputy executive director at unicef
they lose their childhood they are
working like adults
and they have no access to services to
health services
and particularly to education
in response the qatari government banned
using children in camel racing
in 2005. in the years that followed
some 2 000 children were repatriated
back to their home countries
including russell without children in
the saddle
camel racing faced the possibility of
dying
why not use a robot instead of
endangering children
developing the robot proved to be a
challenge
but with perseverance rasheed created
the first robotic jockey
equipped with a thin whip activated by
remote control
the spinning whip motivates the camel to
run faster
now rasheed's friend and colleague
mohammed shakir atta
is experimenting with the new voice
activated model
i thought of recording the voice of the
trainer and the owner of the robot
to a robotic system which is controlled
wirelessly
so i could notice that when you activate
the robot wirelessly
with this voice the camel really reacts
and runs faster
instead of a spinning whip hitting the
animal's leg
the camel will now respond to voice
commands from the owner
robotic jockeys are now widely used by
all gulf
countries this invention not only
protected the lives of children
but saved a traditional sport from
disappearing
and talking of tracks if you're planning
a trip to russia
this next report will show you new ways
of soaking up some of the capital's
historic sites
visitors now have the chance to see
moscow with a fresh eye
by going on a customized urban walking
tour
travelers are treated to many of the
city's hidden gems
highlights that are sure to make their
visit to moscow even more memorable
rit svetlana kirkina has the story
moscow like you've never seen it before
alexander knows that away from the
beaten track the capital
streets have plenty of secrets to review
and buildings that have their stories to
tell
this cinema is more than 100 years old
it was built in 1909.
back then the word cinema didn't exist
in the russian language
so it was called the electric theater
moscow is best explored on foot
that's the idea behind this guided tour
of the city center
it's part of the moscow walks project
aimed at both tourists and locals
it helps you discover places that the
guidebooks overlook
or see familiar sites from an unusual
angle
for 300 rubles you'll spend a couple of
hours hearing about the many stories
from the city's past
tours offered in russian and english all
you have to do is pick the route on the
project's website
and turn up at the appointed place and
time everything which is interesting
is somewhere hidden inside the different
dark nooks different side streets
because
uh the for example the idea of stalin
was to create an ideal mosque
with big highways the idea of cruise
ship was to
move people out of the center and
everything that remained
remain stays still inside side streets
indeed some of moscow's most unusual
places are hidden
literally like this underground bomb
shelter
built in one of moscow's most famous
parks the old russian exhibition center
in the city's north
opened in 1939 the giant park was meant
to showcase
the ussr's industrial and agricultural
achievements
here soviet histories cast in stone
glass and metal
but few had ever known that under the
exhibition central pavilion
there's a secret bunker for top party
elite
with an exit right under the statue of
lenin
this shelter could house up to 300
people there are special rooms which
were for part officials
and even an office which was for the
litter of the country
the shelter was built in 1954 a complex
ventilation system
water supply tanks and even a direct
phone line to the kremlin
all secrets are revealed during the
special guided tour
this summer for the first time since the
fall of the soviet union
the exhibition center launched a series
of excursions
to tell you everything about the iconic
park's history
its architectural gems and its numerous
legends
this is a truly remarkable place with
plenty of historic
and architectural legacy so there's a
lot to discover
we even have an excursion dedicated to
famous love stories linked to this park
we offer tours in a number of foreign
languages and we've also launched
cycling and rollerblading tours and if
nature is your thing
another moscow park kaluminska has come
up with an environmentally
friendly way of enjoying picturesque
landscapes without having to walk for
miles
filled with architectural treasures this
former royal residence is where
generations of russian saws
including ivan the terrible liked to
spend their summers
now for some 200 rubles you can take a
tour of the estate's gardens and
churches
in an electric car with plenty of new
exciting places to discover
there is no excuse for staying at home
and whether it's a stroll through the
city centre or a walk in the park
this summer moscow is set to reveal its
secrets
like never before svetlana correctional
primetime russia
rt well next we head to asia where rice
is a staple food
and bangladesh is no exception there in
the past most bangladeshi farmers
processed the grain by hand a very
labor-intensive and physically taxing
method
while these days rice growers are
increasingly relying on machinery
to help them etv shakawat latan reports
on locally made farm equipment that has
dramatically improved working conditions
many bangladeshis earn their living
through farming of one kind or another
it can be back-breaking work now helping
to ease the burden
10-12 workshops have been set up in the
now gown district to make rice threshing
from our workshop have gone out and
established their own workshops
now work in the other workshops
at first i
threshing has been carried out manually
farmers beat bundles of rice or wheat
against big wooden logs
then oxen trample over the harvested
crop
but now thanks to the new technology
life is becoming
a lot easier
benefits my customers without costing
them much
and the machine can be driven from one
place to another
these workers are busy putting the
finishing touches on these rice and
wheat threshing machines called bongas
some 100 people are employed making them
here
this
will be even more helpful the government
should pay more attention here that
would benefit agriculture in the north
of the country
wheels and an engine have been added to
the machine
so that it can easily be moved about
some people hire the equipment out to
others
it helps people so they buy it it's in
big demand
and i've received orders for a more
sophisticated machine i hope
process
mechanical threshing saves time and only
uses a relatively small amount of fuel
and it can get through a mountain of
work
the threshing machine is a labor-saving
device that's proving
very popular here
now cheetahs are the world's fastest
land animals
and although the cool cats can outrun
any other creature
they're sadly running a race against
extinction in a wildlife park in new
zealand
conservationists are now lending a hand
to help ensure the survival
of that species and others while with
many natural habitats coming under
increasing pressure
sanctuaries such as this one are vital
to protecting some of the world's most
beautiful and distinctive creatures
joe keane from ctv filed this report
tucked behind the christchurch airport
down under in new zealand
on an old river fan from the nearby
waimakariri river
the orana wildlife park has recreated
the wide open spaces
reminiscent of native africa that
provides the perfect backdrop to the
repeated breeding success
of a number of african endangered
species including the southern white
rhino
and cheetah the open range scenario at
iran are very unique compared to many
zoos worldwide
so i think that really lends itself to
the animals some true happiness and
ability to be able to do pretty much as
much as it possibly can
cheetah are faced with extreme threat in
the world and their survival could
ultimately depend on the international
captive breeding programme
like the one offered at arana park
cheetah are a species that
their numbers are declining in the wild
and so they need all the help they can
get really
when it comes to their conservation and
so captive breeding programs whether
it's here in new zealand or
anywhere in the world really are quite
important
the park has had significant success
with their captive breeding program with
18 cheetah being born at the park
a great achievement as cheetah are
notoriously difficult to breed in
captivity
with only a small number of zoos
worldwide achieving repeated success
they seem to like their their space and
peace and quiet and so a lot of those
particularly city zoos i guess don't
have that uh
uh that option for keeping their cheater
in a nice quiet area whereas we've got a
lot of space
we've got the number of yards at the
back that we can do the breeding in
and uh it seems to work iran have had a
number of
litters born over the years here and
a lot of success with their tutoring
keeping the animals and conditions as
close to their natural environment helps
their natural behaviours
and is critical and important feature of
the park as
is the interrelationship with the park's
mix of recreation
education conservation and research
serena's success
definitely lends itself to the fact that
the animals have a lot of space to to
move around
males and the separation of males and
females as in the wild you'll get males
and females that don't occupy the same
habitat they're big spatial distances
and then they come together
and then move apart again and the way
that our facilities are structured
really are key to that arana park
presently has four
female and nine male cheetah with mating
between them being optimal at three
years
and a gestation period of 90 to 98 days
we try and keep it as natural as we
possibly can in captivity
we've got the males and females
completely separate so what we have to
do is
walk the males up to the females pretty
much every day when it comes to breeding
the reason for doing that is to keep the
interest up with the
boys and the girls as well so they don't
see each other all the time and get
quite comfortable
around each other the integrity of the
species is insured by an international
cheetah stud register
which carefully manages the population
of captive cheetah to ensure the genetic
bloodlines can be kept strong
and ethical as many cheetah are now born
in captivity
they are either mother or hand raised
and the relationship between the keeper
and the animals is critical for their
health it's great to be able to be a bit
more hands-on with their cheetah so if
if there are any health issues or
anything we can treat them
quite well being hands-on and also for
example with females
even getting to the point of being able
to take blood from them very important
that a relationship develops both ways
they need to be able to trust us
and get to know us and that can take
depending on the animal it can take a
month or so
but we also need to know them and know
their individual behaviors because
wild animals generally can be pretty
subtle in their
in their behavior changes if they're
sick or injured they tend not to show it
because obviously in the wild if they're
sick or injured they're going to be
vulnerable
and so you really need to look for those
very subtle changes sometimes so you
need to
know your animals quite intimately to be
able to pick those
those changes unfortunately the impact
of human activity has meant the captive
breeding program
may be the only link to cheetah and many
other species survival
i think the cohabitation animals and
human beings and the impact we as human
beings
make on animals habitats if we're
dealing specifically with the cheetah
it was so widespread it was an animal
there was exceptionally widespread
throughout africa and over the years
we've literally encroached in their
habitat taken over
brought in our agricultural practices
it's driven their prey base away and
basically taken away what they need to
survive
so it's how we as human beings can can
interact with the animals and try and
retain them in the most sort of pristine
natural way possible without
impacting on on their environment the
second largest surviving land animal
next to the elephant is the southern
white rhino
which faces extreme threats especially
from poaching in the wild
arana park currently is home to seven
southern white rhino
with the youngest eco born at the park
on may the first 2010.
at one stage there are only 30 southern
white rhino left in the wild
but with the establishment of the
captive breeding programs this outlook
has improved dramatically
humans tend to put themselves at the top
of the food chain and the most important
things on the planet and and sadly
nature and wildlife has become second
best in many places in the world
the political influences are dictated
around what you do for people not so
much wildlife
around a park office adopt an animal
program giving the public an opportunity
to help raise funds to ensure the
continued success
of the captive breeding program however
it's time we all started to think about
the sustainability of our unique
wildlife
in their present habitats and the
pressure human intrusion is causing
now with the summer in europe winding
down and the weather already getting a
little chilly
it's a sure sign that halloween isn't
far from around the corner
but we don't need to wait until then to
share scary stories about haunted places
we can just
all head for la isla de las muniecas in
mexico
where they've made it their business to
scare visitors out of their wits
and if you think you know what spooky is
wait until you see this
some people earn their living making
dolls and some of us give dolls to our
children
who play with them and take them to bed
each night but here on this island south
of mexico city they have another purpose
to ward off evil spirits
local legend has it that many years ago
a girl drowned in the canal by don
julian's house
and since that faded day her soul has
found no peace
and canals and in the trash
they took them with him and hung
in the year 1950 don julian began to
collect dolls in the hope that they
would protect him from the ghost
lurking in the canals of sochi miko
that's how the island of dolls came into
being
the door with the
if you look closely you can see that
it's at least 60 years old
it's from 1950 the year the girl died
but only one of them has a name
agustinita
or the spoiled one
he believed that she had the power to
protect people from evil
and at home with their families at
school
wherever
hold it's the mysticism and secrecy
surrounding these dolls
it's said that agustinita can make every
wish come true
not only the island's inhabitants think
so many european visitors returned to
reward her with money or new dresses
i just ask her that i stay healthy have
enough to eat
and enough work it's not as if i have
these two baskets of food two lemonades
and two beers because of this enchanted
door
we still have to work if we want to buy
something
and the dolls do more than just grant
wishes
anastasio tells us about the strange
things that happen after
dark
some of them can move my uncle impressed
upon me that i must never make up
stories
but sometimes i do hear a canoe coming
and women's voices
if i pick them up they scream as if they
had batteries
when i go to bed it sounds like
somebody's tidying up
or i feel someone touching me when my
uncle was alive he'd go out in his
trainers with his stick
and you can still hear him people say
they would ask him what he wants
but i'm afraid to see i tell them
i don't believe them
i'd like to see if they're still so
brave all alone in the middle of the
night
you have any light no i only have
candles
i'll spin
anastasio has spent many sleepless
nights here
the island's atmosphere and strange
noises don't give him a moment's piece
but leaving is out of the question
people ask why i don't just leave if i'm
so afraid
but i have nowhere else to go i grow my
vegetables here
then i go off to sell them then i return
his uncle don julian died in the same
spot as the girl who drowned
some say his heart failed others say he
was claimed by the ghost
did the dolls stop protecting him
no one lives forever people die at home
in the street or wherever they happen to
be we all have to die sometimes
it's all just a folk tale but there's
only one way to find out
if you head to the koemanco pier you can
take a boat straight to don julian's
island of dolls
but beware some say the ghosts haven't
had their fill of souls just yet
well on that creepy note we've come to
the end of this edition of world stories
we hope that we haven't scared you away
and that you'll join us again next week
thanks so much for watching
remember you can always find us online
at dw
dot d-e world stories now here are this
week's picks of the world see you next
time
me wolves
you